alright we're live welcome everybody to
another hangout super excited today to
have one of my friends James called on
with me and he is studying up a new
podcast called the inspired life and
asked if I would be a guest on his show
and so I thought absolutely let's do it
and why don't we also turn it into a
video so that you guys can learn more
about him his website is a James Calder
co uk i'll link it up in the description
below to see guys gonna check out what
what he's up to site is still being
worked on because the podcast doesn't
come out till March is like a sneak
preview for you guys but James welcome
aboard man I appreciate that so much I'm
so happy that you got the pronunciation
of my surname right as well I gather
what do people call you I get everything
I get I had clad that before I've had
Kaldur everything but when he said that
and I was like this guy he just gets it
he understands it alright we're ahead of
the game I like I you know but I do
butcher people's names there are some
names and I have no idea how to
pronounce but call there that seems it
seems easy enough quotes my favorite one
when people butcher I love that people
go i'll try to remember in this quote a
minute but i'm probably going to butcher
it okay well let's let's turn over you
you have your usual podcast intro use
that and then we're going to be talking
about living inspired life so I'm ready
to answer your questions awesome
preciate right welcome to the inspired
life my friend how are you I'm good how
are you fantastic it's it's exciting and
surreal and nerve-wracking to finally
knock spend some time with you so I
appreciate you coming on ever so much if
if I may I just want to start by and by
how much I admire your consistency now
I've been following your journey for
just over two years and you've uploaded
over 2,400 videos since 2007 so very
much congrats on that those are those of
the public ones another like 600 that
are not listed wow yeah that's pretty
intense what's been the most exciting
moment of you then in your
youtube journey since that first video
was uploaded back in two thousand seven
ah exciting sing I don't know man you
know the best part for me is just
watching the comments ah the best part I
mean even meeting you right like you
know you feel you know me you've had a
you've grown by listening to my stuff
that means something to me like it's
that's why I do it and I'm lucky enough
now that I get that on a regular basis
where every day I get comments and
people tell me how much they love the
stuff at the start it was harder because
nobody comments on your stuff and like
one common would give me fuel for the
next two weeks they keep going till I
got my next comment but i think the
that's just a highly it's a daily rush
it's a daily like I still love looking
at my comments every day and seeing what
people are saying and the impact that
we're having and I get to share that
with my team and I don't know that a
single moment or single comment um but
but that's what's meaningful for me but
there's certain feelings that you get in
that you wouldn't really be able to sort
of Express is that it's those comments
is by engagement and this is going to be
about the hero's journey today about
believe in yourself because we are just
getting started out so before we get
going like really diving into it young
be for us to dive into gratitude for a
moment diving or whatever you want man
is a criteria game whatever you want to
ask i'll answer honestly right well
gratitude is assuming that i live and
breathe so I want to ask why are you
most grateful for recently in your life
is funny because I have a habit that I
don't consistently do you talk about
consistency is when I'm working on but
basically waking up and thinking of
three things that I'm grateful for uh
the ones that always come to the top of
the list or is my family and people for
my wife and grateful for my son for my
parents you know permeability being
healthy and alive and then sometimes it
goes more macro like I'm grateful for my
country I'm grateful that I can live in
Canada and I love my city and my friends
sometimes you know I greipel for the Sun
I'm grateful for the bed that I'm in you
know like it gets just whatever comes to
mind
um I think just having a daily ritual
where you are trying to express
gratitude and think about it uh makes
you happier and more appreciative that
doesn't mean I want I don't want more
right like I want to I want more growth
I want more it's like this constant um
it's not maybe fighting that I kind of
they seem opposite but they're not like
I'm if nothing else happened if I had no
more growth on my youtube channel that
was like the end I would still be super
grateful and happy with what I've built
but then still I want more right like I
want to do more I want to impact more
lies we want to have a bigger reach I
know my time on this planet is limited
and I want to be able to touch as many
people as I can gratitude was not
something that I did much of I guess in
my younger years I don't know if I read
a book or where I heard about it from
but I find that helpful and interesting
just to start the day with a little bit
of gratitude and recognize that this is
a great life that I have and and that I
should be appreciative and thankful and
recognize it regularly and you built it
through consistency and like with
gratitude sometimes I'll just wake up
and just look around at things and just
be like I'm grateful for that uu x
they're ungrateful for you so yeah yeah
i think what helps is um it just makes
you happy I just put you in a better
mood at least for me and I find this a
great way to start your day if you start
your day looking me behind about sleep
or maybe you're stressed out about some
project you're working on or whatever
I'm just starting the day with a little
bit of gratitude puts you in a good mood
and and just sets up the rest of your
day sets up like that next call you have
to take instead of being angry with that
person now you're you realize that that
you know so it's a small thing in
comparison to where you're going in your
life and maybe your little happier on
that call maybe that turns into a much
bigger opportunity because of the just a
change in your demeanor so I'm not super
consistent on it but i'd like to get
better and the up there you go you're
motivating me to make that gratitude
three times there are three things every
morning more consistent I like it that's
cool then we'll step it up before and
I'm five and
your morning routine adjust be gratitude
then I want to talk about how this all
began because you're a speaker you're an
author if we just go real for a moment
you're a mentor you're very active in
the YouTube scene so there's a lot of
different things happening few but how
did it all begin did it did it start
with you simply sending out your good
vibes in front of a camera how did your
sort of hashtag believe message or begin
um so I guess I could break it down the
two things 1i started helping
entrepreneurs before I thought about
believe I had my first company when I
was 19 I almost quit I told my partner I
quit it was the most amazing and
terrible experience in my life I guess
and when I I went from making 300 l's a
month and being below the poverty line
in like just sucking to selling my
business in three years for seven
figures and a lot happened on that
journey but we can get into if you want
but what happened after that was man I
wanted to help other entrepreneurs were
going through that same thing like I
wish there was somebody to help me
through the path that I had to go
through and YouTube wasn't a thing back
then and you know there was articles and
stuff but there wasn't anything you know
super valuable so that's why I started
just I didn't have a business model
behind it it was just I love helping
entrepreneurs I started by doing
presentations I did workshops and went
to a local YMCA and offered to do a free
workshop for their entrepreneurs either
walk did entrepreneur program get the
ymca in the UK something yeah yeah yeah
I'm not see for me I gotta be honest I'm
not too familiar with it known so I
can't mean spanned into it that much
yeah the ymc is just like it's a
community organization that tries to
help the local they do a lot of athletic
stuff they put on programs and my local
YMCA had entrepreneurship class I said
hey how about I come and help your
entrepreneurs I you know built my
business up and sold it and I did a
session for them and I got so excited I
was so nervous like I gotta got two
hours of them we got to put in like my
best stuff you know really
these guys out and I promoted it they
promoted it and then I showed up and and
three people in the room and it was
super devastating I thought you know
this is not how am I going to ever make
a career off of this if I only had three
people to come to a free thing that
we've both been promoting and how am I
going to turn into a business but those
three people showed up so I decided
let's let's do it you know I'm going to
try to help these three people and it
was amazing you know I just I felt so
good it was such a rush to help these
three people and know that i had an
impact on them and that they were
motivated and they had ideas to go and
grow their business but just I had to
find a way to keep doing even if I never
made money oh just I had to keep doing
it and I did more presentations and more
presentations and ended up speaking we
filled up the wives here and then I
moved to a bookstore and we filled up
the bookstore and had you know we had
one event where we had the second-most
number of people at this bookstore show
up the first was when sting came and was
doing his book tour so second the sting
is not bad but I still never had a
business model I didn't have sponsors it
was just me speaking because I love to
help when these entrepreneurs and I took
time out of what I was doing to help
these guys out and then that just
transitioned at some point to making
videos I don't know if somebody
recommended it or what I'm always been
I've always been a visual learner I much
rather watch a video then then read
something oriya listen to something I
like I wanted to see it right it was
that was me um and so I just started
making videos and the first one sucked
and I sucked on camera and they were
brutal and you know but I just started
because I wanted to you know somebody
would ask me questions and I would take
you know half an hour right in a
response on emails that this is not a
good use of my time even though it
really helped that person like I was
running out of time so that I can make a
video i can send it to them and then
anybody else had that same problem could
watch the video believe came a little
bit later i believe happened so
you know my my one word is believe it's
on the wall it's on my shirt on the back
I believe that everybody has one word
that kind of defines them when you
figure that out it helps you live on on
purpose as opposed to just reacting to
the world around you so my word is
believed it has always been a part of
who I am I believed in entrepreneurs I
did all this stuff for free just to help
out and when I realized that then it
helped me make smarter decisions um it
came out of I had I had my website I was
growing content I was adding stuff on
there and the website started to become
a it's an advertising game and you just
you put up articles and you know the
more search they are the more revenue
would get and it became a game where I I
handed that off to my team and I turn
into something that was just let's try
to get as many articles as we could
regardless of if it's meaningful helpful
or impactful just like try to rank and
get get ad dollars and I spent less and
less time in that business and started
spending more and more time doing stuff
that I was interested was actually
having a meaningful impact on people's
lives um and I got frustrated looking at
the website said okay we now we got to
change this you know we gotta this isn't
this isn't Who I am um and I was trying
to think about what do I what do I with
my tagline what do I call myself I had a
bunch over the years from hungry
entrepreneurs is sort of help to over 20
million entrepreneurs helped and
Counting to a bunch of different things
and I got to believe by just writing
down lists of words that I felt were
core values to me and believed was one
of them i had this list and then I look
at it the next day and some people get
this instinctively like some people just
know I didn't have the self-awareness to
really know um the next I looked at the
list and I like believe but i believe is
too short believe you can that's like
it's it's too big it's too bold to say
something you got to be more specific
yeah what do you believe in right and
then the more I looked at it the more I
tried to add
stuff to it the less I I like those
additions and then I just became more
comfortable with believe and then that
became that became the mantra and if you
look at my past I mean the idea of
finding your one word if you look you
look back at your life and it's been
consistent it's not just your word for
the year this is something that's always
been there so you know the movies that i
watch are about inspiring the little guy
you know the songs i listen to our the
uplifting you know believe kind of songs
the friends that I gravitate towards the
you know people in my life they believe
in what I'm doing and so you could do
the same exercise and find yours so but
that started after i was already helping
entrepreneurs the the helping
entrepreneurs came out of the
frustration of me being an entrepreneur
and not having great resources to help
me and then believe came out of the
frustration of feeling like i wanted to
do something a little more meaningful
impactful while and what what actually
we got from LA then and it felt like a
new idea really was when you mentioned
the ymca i thought myself i'm gonna
contact the ymca tomorrow go for it and
actually to be honest that entire
message they was about Givaudan given
service wait for other people and
gilding up a reputation and then being
able to sort of offer a service then and
i was thinking the entire time men i'm
gonna contact ymca well here's the thing
ah when you're starting a business or
when you're doing anything you like that
your passion about you have to put to
get good at it you have to put a
disproportionate amount of time into it
to get good at it to build the skill set
to build the momentum behind it most
people quit because it's too hard
because they're not willing to put in
the work that doesn't make sense like
it's illogical if you looked at how much
work it takes to make this successful
it's illogical does not make sense to do
and so the only thing that gets you
through is is the love of the process
not just a result but i love the process
so for those of people listening
thinking yeah i should contact
I'm ca2 if all you do is look at as a
marketing strategy and it's not going to
work it's like you love the idea of
talking to people at the way you love
the idea of helping out local
entrepreneurs right ymc or some other
groups is tons of groups so I think
that's where a lot of people fall down
they pick up on the marketing strategies
and they all going to try that but they
don't stick with it long enough to get
really good at it and to really have an
impact and so they quit is because they
don't enjoy the process so you got to
enjoy what you do not just you got enjoy
the journey right not just where you're
trying to go I don't know about a
logical comment then because when you
Stein you're not going to be making
minimum wage an hour you could be
spending 12 hours a day less look like
yeah plugging away on something be my
actually be making nothing and that
could go on for use yankee hill trying
to learn more work so i was making three
hundred dollars a month looks like
nothing I had to pick you know my
friends want to go for four beers and
pizza and like I could i I couldn't go
right like I had to pick one thing a
month that I could go to because that's
all it because twenty dollars was too
much I didn't have it and I was too
embarrassed to tell my friends because
they thought I'm living the entrepreneur
lifestyle you know I got my own boss
right and I was too embarrassed to say
guys I'm like massively struggling I
have no idea what I'm doing that was
like too much pride and ego I guess of
former me embarrassment uh and so why
did I keep doing it like any logical
sane rational person would have stopped
just I loved it and you when you love
something you find a way to do it it's
illogical I know the feeling all too
well I really really do so I can relate
Evan what were you like in school were
there any particular classes that your
your energy then and your ambition
really shine through was there was there
a particular teacher that inspired you
because I find that when you're around
people that make you feel good in your
own skin then you know it really does
saw change your perspective and it's
great to have these influences around
you but what we've liked in school
I was never a fantastic student I wasn't
a terrible student my parents had high
expectations like two sisters one older
one younger both my sisters were like
straight a students did fantastically
well I was sitting like bc students not
failing but always below the family
expectations every time we had a report
card come back I always had to go have
the talk with my parents to their
bedroom and sit down and talk with
what's going on the thing that you know
believe I think a lot of it comes from
them they always told me that I macos
truly carmike on I could do anything I
wanted and my mother saw same as cuz
truly my middle name is Gus chili and so
that's at your tradition I carry on to
my son his name is Hayden and so you
know we'll say I'm hating Carmichael and
I can do anything and he'll like yell
anything like he's six years old and
he's into it but I think that that
self-belief and self-confidence came
from them were even if my teachers uh
didn't like something I did I remember
lling was an art project that we were
given and I did my own interpretation of
it and my art teacher you know didn't
like it and I didn't get a good score on
it and then he showed my parents and my
parents stood up for me said hey listen
he just did it this way it's still what
you wanted and you know said the stupid
teacher made me like back me up right
like I kind of do something different
and they always they always had my back
and we believe in myself there was a
point in in in high school where my own
expectations exceeded my parents
expectations for the first time of what
i thought i could do i don't know why i
don't know where that came from there's
basically the year where i graduated i
just decided to turn up and but ok my
parents want me to get you know straight
A's and my like 80 wasn't good enough
anymore and i ended up getting straight
90s in my last year and i don't know why
i don't know i don't remember anything
specific happening maybe I blocked it
from my memory so I was like I was
always an okay student I think I I
always look for different way
a an unconventional way which helps me
immensely as an entrepreneur I always
look for like faster ways to get
something done and shortcuts and doesn't
always make the teachers massively happy
people who like like to go by the book
uh not that I clash their fought or like
got kicked out of school or any of that
stuff there's still like a I had a
healthy respect for authority just I
like to I like to find another way and
that wasn't always encouraged I guess in
school it's great as an entrepreneur you
know you get to find your own path and
do exactly what you want to do um so
yeah I mean I thought I want to be a
banker my huskily yearbook we have to
write down I don't you have a tradition
in England boat we don't a tradition in
here in North America is a yearbook at
the end of the year that shows all the
students and like recaps all the events
from this that year school year and put
together by the students and then the
graduating class is all there and it
usually shows them when they were young
at the school and now wouldn't graduate
in their photos and they ask you
questions and one of the questions is
always where you see yourself in 10
years everybody answers and puts on
their thing and mine was banker I
thought it was gonna be a banker in 10
years time in 10 years yeah like VP at a
bank is what I put on my resume I didn't
have entre period like my parents
weren't entrepreneurs my you know my
friend's parents weren't entrepreneurs
so that's what i thought i was going to
do i'm so happy i didn't do that but
what do you parents them think veena
then they proud they've always been
proud uh my my parents the most
important thing with this is good good
props to my parents on this one is that
they both had very safe stable you know
my dad worked for the government for his
whole life basically and even though
they lived in a pretty safe world
themselves they they always encouraged
the kids to do whatever they wanted so
I'm actually the safest of all the kids
like my my older sister started the
business moved to California my younger
sister went to Africa
just on a whim and then it up staying
there for 10 years working for the UN
and going into danger zones and getting
like danger pay and fighting you know
trying to try to get child soldiers to
like stop fighting and to you know it's
like just insane stuff which gave my
parents heart attacks but they they've
always been proud of us for doing their
most important things they want us to be
happy they want to chase our dreams to
live the life that we want to live which
is a lot harder life than a simple get a
job you know go work for company 925
kind of existence and so I think that's
the greatest thing that they instilled
in all of us is the confidence to chase
what we want to do even if it's crazy
like they were always there even if it
was they may not understand what we're
doing then I'll be able to give
practical advice like oh you should do
this you know I can't go to them with
business problems but they were always
there to help us emotionally and give us
a confidence to do whatever we wanted to
do and I try to instill that now into my
son to I think it's the one of the best
gifts that you can pass on well I can I
can see why people love you my boy
people love your belief message um so
learning then has been a big thing for
you obviously from school you said you
came out with B's and C's which I was
exactly the same I didn't do great in
school either and so my next question is
because I think self-learning then is
obviously the next big thing could you
see people on YouTube nowadays they
building massive YouTube brands and
that's just because they're passionate
about what they do and they're
passionate about how they use in their
time how important is learning new
skills and improving your mind view so
are you reading a lot are you listening
to podcasts do you watch other YouTube
videos what basically gives you that
high end of personal development when
you well when do you make time for it as
well yeah this is super important
because I believe you're a product of
your environment
and you'll find that most people never
break free from their environment most
people end up like their parents why'd
you think that is it's your environment
like there's nothing there's no spark
like for me one of the sparks was
connecting with those two entrepreneurs
in university I thought I was going to
be a banker those two people who had
that company that I was then invited to
join as a owner in that set me on a new
path if I didn't meet them I would have
gone the path that was that my friends
were going down and my parents went down
that's not that it's nothing there's
nothing wrong with that necessarily just
uh you are a part of your environment is
that there's a saying that you're going
to make as much money as your five
closest friends and it's true and you
would take on their mindset you take on
their mentality and so if you want to do
great things you have to be surrounded
by greatness and so look at your
environment look at you know there's a
reason why I wear this is the reason why
this is on the wall it's not just for
you it's for me right like I want to
come in and I want to be inspired right
you can't see well I got other stuff
happening here with dunno its kind of
narrow view on here but um you know
where you work matters right the the
lighting in your place matters what's on
the wall matters the information that
you feed yourself matters are you
watching uh you know reality TV shows
are you watching something that's going
to fill you up do the people around you
say you're crazy or do they try to help
you accomplish your dreams uh you know
the reason why I made the ants presso
and top 10 videos on my channel was
because I wanted to be surrounded by
great ideas like regularly every day
right what happens to most people is
they may stumble on something like maybe
they stumble on this interview right
like oh you know James has this thing I
heard about it from some tweet and I'm
gonna go check it out great they
listened to it they're inspired I'm
going to live an inspired life yes it's
five o'clock on thursday afternoon
they're off like rest of the night
they're up to three in the morning like
planning their life everything you're
going to do then wake up the next day
they're certain over again like the
motivation is gone and at least for me
that's what happens for me like I'll
watch something and get inspired and
then
next day you wake up and it's like I'm
starting from scratch again and so I
need to create an environment that
supports that bigger thinking
breakthrough thinking on a regular basis
and so you know I surround myself with
videos from Bill Gates and Steve Jobs
and Walt Disney in you know big thinkers
who've done huge things every day that's
how I start my day you know and that
makes me think bigger and realize that
these guys started in a position that is
often worse than how I started and were
able to create these huge things and
maybe I won't reach those heights but I
can do a lot better than what i'm doing
right now and if i look at the things
around me most people live a life
without serious intention you know i
wish i could be this but they don't
believe it and they don't have the
environment that supports them so like
what is your morning routine you start
with gratitude great most people most
people don't have a morning routine that
is designed its I wake up I get coffee I
rush to work you know put on my clothes
whatever you want to design it
especially that first start I find that
when you have when you have something
easy to do in the morning that sets you
up like if it's gratitude and you keep
that habit you're much more likely to
keep the other positive habits if you
miss it you mr. gratitude have but you
miss one of the whatever your first one
is then it's easy to know I'm not going
to work out either and I'm not gonna I'm
not going to go read that book either
and I'll just start over tomorrow and
you just like throw away the day so I
want to throw a few days as possible but
the overall concept is if you want to do
great things you surrounded by greatness
so everything around you your daily
routine your your environment what you
consume the media that you you know put
into your ears or into your eyes that it
all matters that helps you accomplish
things you need to push you need
something to push you beyond your
comfort zone and most people don't have
that in their lives they don't have
friends or family or anybody to push
them beyond and it's uncomfortable to go
beyond and so you don't
we don't do the things that are painful
and uncomfortable in general so that's
why most people never escape their
environment you've literally just broke
down self-esteem 101 right there I love
that and one one thing i was thinking
now and you actually you inspired this
question it wasn't when I was initially
going to ask but then I was thinking
about a college student and I was also
thinking about someone who maybe works a
job maybe like nine to five and they
can't necessarily change their
environment too much because they work
in at a set location and the still in
school at the moment what are some
things then and some influences some
ways that they can adjust their
environment is this thing that they
maybe have to do when they get home
later on is that they can change around
their morning routine mention a lot
about motivation Lee and I personally
think it's having a reason why me being
your down time then to go out and build
something so that's kind of my thought
on it like personally I've kept morning
gratitude routine now haven't broken it
for one day in over two years and I feel
like that helps me build self-esteem in
other areas as well because I know I can
consistently keep a routine that is
empowering to me but going back to the
college student and maybe the person
that someone who has a job where they
can't change their environment what are
some ways and then they can influence
you said about information they take in
or just some key rituals and routines
yeah so let's all attack them a couple
levels to first you know everybody has
24 hours in a day you me Bill Gates
Richard Branson everybody has 24 hours
you know nobody gets extra now you're
spending how Romanies sleeping five six
seven eight nine hours sleeping whatever
your time awake you have a chance to
influence what you consume what your
habits are you know who you're hanging
out with even if you say I can't change
because I'm a college student or I have
a job we'll leave that aside for now
there's still tons of hours that you are
not at your job
or at college right so what are you
doing with those hours right where are
you living right you could transform
your room when you wake up what do you
see around you what's on the walls is
the things that inspire you or is it
another boring wall right if you wake up
to a barn wall you're probably have a
boring day right like you want to set
yourself up for greatness every day I
what's your first thing what's the first
thing you do every day after you wake up
do you write a gratitude journal do you
watch a YouTube video do you you know
fill your head with with you review your
goals and fill yourself up with what you
want to get done for the day and what do
you do that makes you like I find I need
to do it every day I wake up but I'm I
need to get the the motivation the
excitement for me it's from the YouTube
comments like I look at the comments and
that you okay yes are ya okay I look at
the comments and and it just it makes me
feel like hey the stuff that I'm doing
isn't is important like it's massively
touching people's lives I need to keep
doing it that that's fuel for me but for
the young college student or whoever you
want to fill yourself up in the morning
with something that makes you come alive
and then what do you do on your way to
work you know what are you listening to
you listening to audiobooks so you
listen to this podcast you know are you
listening to music that gets you pumped
up and excited or you just sitting on
the subway with your head down and
buried and just like tired because you
don't have enough sleep or whatever it
like these are all moments if you take
10 minutes out of your daily routine and
did something a little more empowering
especially in the morning that has a
ripple effect on the rest of your day
you know and then didn't come over time
yeah and then ideally you do is you take
those 10 minutes and it becomes 20 and
30 like you dissect your life into 10
minute chunks and try to make the most
out of each chunk that you have if we
talk it from a higher level you know if
you're not happy about as a college
student you have a terrible college
environment of your terrible work
environment it might also make you think
is this actually what I should be doing
right like should I be at that college
should I be studying this topic or not
like do I want to spend the next five
six seven years of my life studying this
top
maybe you shouldn't write if you're if
you're waking up every day dreading to
go here maybe you shouldn't do that
anymore right the reason to get a job is
not to make money is to learn so you
want to work somewhere where you're
going to get skills and learn and
improve yourself and have an inspired
life right so are you getting that at
your job if not well maybe you shouldn't
be working there either right like if
there are things that you dread doing on
a daily basis maybe you shouldn't do
those for too long right like if it's
pushing you if it's if it's making you a
better version of yourself and it's
pushing you to get stronger then yes
like that fear is something that you
should conquer and get better at but if
it's just something that's like you're
dying and you're drowning end and then
maybe you just don't accept that as I
can't change my environment maybe you
shouldn't be doing that at all and go do
something else that's more inspired wow
so on this is another question you've
now inspired then do you try to balance
your life when you have so much going on
excuse me I need a drink of water I'm
got so much going on and that you're
passionate about like I read in your 99
word bio and you love salsa dancing you
love the blue jays you love Liga legends
yeah big fan and look me up I'm believe
team on the North American server nice
nice so I'm serious well kind of weaned
off at ever so slightly but serious
video game nerd with an OCD for personal
development so I'm gonna do that later
on I just play on it like two or three
hours ago I'm not very good but I like
it I'm silver five or something so I
stopped playing it cuz I was too good I
was a was my thing I'm coming balance
I'm gonna come drum dad grab a drink of
water go for it for balance here's what
I find um on a regular day I do you know
if I find myself doing too much of
something in general then I'll feel out
of whack like if I haven't spent time
with my wife for my son I'll feel it you
know like I'll feel I'll get edgy in
like I need to I need that time I need
the downtown I need to spend time salsa
dancing if I don't I start to feel it um
there are moma
ends in time where you push through
because you're on an adrenaline rush
because something is so important that
you're like you could push other things
aside you know like you're playing a
game a league and it's ranked you know
you got a marathon going on you don't
need to go to the washroom yeah like I'm
gonna hold it I'm going to hold it in
right and then game ends in you jet
right so the same thing can happen like
I just finished right in my book and I
have 20 review copies going out to
people and so yesterday was all about
getting all the review copies together
connecting with all the people who are
going to be sending it to I met up with
nine of them yesterday and like handing
them out and signing each one and so
like that took a huge chunk of my day
and that was time that i didn't spend
with my wife i didn't spend at home we
didn't spend doing salsa I didn't been
doing league didn't spend doing other
stuff but it's okay like every now and
then that happens about if that was
every day then I would I would I would
burn out like I can't I can't do this I
need to spend time it's like travelling
for me now is too much I just came out
from Seattle working with Microsoft on a
project and like I don't want to go
traveling anymore because i miss what
i'm doing here too much and so i think
what's helpful is to have somewhat of a
daily routine or weekly routine of where
you're going to spend time and schedule
the things that are important in your
personal life into your schedule just
like you would business stuff and there
will be times when there's some crazy
things that happened that the overlap
right it happens on the personal side to
write like uh my mom was in a car
accident recently and flipped her Jeep
when a dog right across the street so
you know now like are you okay right
like business is now all off to the side
and we're all worried about her and she
is everything's okay but you okay now
happy what's that she ok now it's okay
yeah I thank you she's ok but but at the
moment it's scary it's crazy and you
push everything else aside to handle
this issue so I think for from regular
days I have a daily I have a weekly
routine I things I do a monday tuesday
wednesday thursday friday thursday is my
public facing day as an example we're
doing this interview on a thursday
because that's the day that i spend
talking to people um but there are some
days
a business you know something huge
happens and you take advantage of and
personal it could be a good or bad thing
that blows up your day I just try to
minimize those as much as possible
obviously can't control you know my
mother get into a car accident I you
know I can't control some of the things
on the business side but I try as much
as possible to keep a regular routine
where there is some kind of balance
because if it goes to out of whack then
I'm not happy and at the end like this
all is here to try to make me be happy
this is about Evan being happiest with
this what I'm trying to do I love that
so much and because we're on blab right
now we got someone who is absolutely
loving your message saying saying that
Evan you're so helpful and that's why I
like about you you're not just trying to
sell stuff so Evan we all love you right
this next question then and it was a
silly I was asked this question a few
days ago it was on my daily commute to a
coffee shop and really quick shout out
to the guys income Brancaster you're
doing a fantastic job and I bumped into
a friend my own spunk German few months
and we got talking about what were you
working on right now this was the
conversation about about the podcasts in
and he wasn't too sure which I think we
just talked about this before we side it
wasn't too sure where our podcast was
and as I gobble basically I'm a radio
show host if you if you're not sure rare
yeah try explaining and but the
conversation got me thinking about a
mission statement um I'm gonna hand this
one over to you now and this question
what is your mission statement this is a
serve words and your mission statement
for me it's I believe in entrepreneurs
and that that always generates interest
and an a conversation um my my
longer-term kind of goal is I wanna be
able to help a billion entrepreneurs but
if you look at my my social media buyers
across every you know Twitter Facebook
it all just says I hashtag believe in
entrepreneurs I think whenever you're
picking a mission statement has to be
something that actually means something
to you like deeply you know like
Eve is on the wall some of my marketing
but it's not it's not for marketing like
I didn't do that because of marketing
this comes from available very real
place I mean hopefully it comes across
on this video and it comes across in all
the videos that I do uh it has to be
something that's deeply meaningful and
what and when I hire people I always
lead with the mission we lead with you
know we believe in entrepreneurs and
we've designed this business to help
entrepreneurs and if you don't know then
that that attracts people who have the
same mission you know Christina who's my
video editor I almost got a tattoo that
said to leave across her arm Wow before
meeting me like because she loves
believe like that's her personal mission
to do you yeah it took like it's it's
attracting people who have the same
mindset and and it attracts customers it
attracts suppliers it attracts investors
it attracts employees I think most
people never uh never put that out they
don't even know what they stand for and
so they attract randomness where I you
know some people will see if I do a job
postings i'm looking for a believe
videographer you know a lot of people
would see that and then lead leave see
the intro all about believe in
entrepreneur and say this is the
stupidest thing I've ever seen in my
life right great not separable I if I
had one I do that all the time like
fantastic I we would not work well
together right I don't want you as my
videographer it's great and there are
other people who look at that thing wow
this is awesome and so that when you
leave with your values that helps
attract the right people to team because
you don't want just you know so you're
making a podcast I don't know if you
need to you need to hire website website
developer or you need to hire anybody
else on your team to help you build up
your business you don't want just any
website developer it's a commodity
service you want somebody who believes
in living an inspired life like you
can't have people working for you who
don't want to live an inspired life and
inspire others to live in inspired life
like somebody who's doing it just just
for the money to be a web developer it's
not going to give you their best stuff
and so if you're not
forthright about it if you just hold
these values we all have them we all
value different things if you just hold
it in and you don't explain it then
you're just going to attract those
random people instead of purposely
attracting the right people to your
business well I'm hooking mereb that you
lead by your values less powerful I
think you said your value was believed
mine person I can bring it down to one
my message is obviously believing in
yourself that's the message of the book
but now I have this funny story in there
about the day that I learned about
laughter because I will I never used to
I always took myself too seriously I was
always trying to be perfect and now I
think my values are loved laughs and
inspire and I know doesn't have the word
believe in me and I think it helps me
with himself with like I don't measure
productivity to self worth anymore which
is something I massively used to do I
thought from not being productive then
it would damage my self-esteem and the
values leading by those values being
able to love laugh and inspire things
really really helped out so much with
just my overall focus and my
productivity and how much meaning i
bring to i can bring to work now and
that's something personally that I see
in all of the videos and i think it's i
think is for that affirmation you've got
standing behind you that allows you to
bring out so much i'm just gonna use
with authenticity i am and i appreciate
you sharing that with us and so i'm
gonna share with your mind which is I
broke this is written down in front of
me now the big grin slapped across my
face is that this is my measurement
mission statement right now and and I've
had a few people sort of helping with
this actually is to inspire and educate
1 million people to believe themselves
and do more of what they love and what
makes them laugh because I believe if
everybody has taken the time to pursue
what's important to them and that
doesn't have to be build a business or
work towards somebody else's definition
of success but more of why I use them to
live a good life doing the things that
you're most passionate about I believe
that's the gift of well-being and it's
also like a cure for
pain and inner gremlins so I think that
our relationships are going to be better
and people are going to do what they
love and feel like what they do matters
they was with Lana missin in that there
really was no that's okay i think i'm
going to feedback on your own speaker um
i think i think the challenge with i
think the challenge of like you look at
companies they all have a mission
statement they all have values y'all
have a mission statement how many people
in the company can actually recite the
mission statement he actually knows what
the vast a CEO of any you know footsie
company what their top ten core values
are and they won't know most the vision
what are you working towards so so the
point of getting it down to the one word
at least for me is clarity right like
people know me is the believe guy right
they remember it they embody it they can
share it where the longer your thing is
the harder it is for you to remember and
then you're like I my mission is to this
I left something now it's like if you
don't remember then how is it actually
guiding you right so this is a challenge
with a lot of company mission statements
for me there's also difference between
the word and then with the hashtag
because I think you can assign your own
meaning so for me believe versus hashtag
believe is different because believe is
just uh most people think it believed
was just self confidence which it is for
me that's a big part of it but it's also
equally important for me is believing in
what you're doing so having passion for
what you're doing right that's still
that's still hashtag belief for me
you're believing in what you're doing
and then believing that's going to work
out so not just self confidence but
that's that's what gives me persistence
right you talked about persistent I'm
consistent because I believe that it's
going to work out and so those three
ideas form hashtag believe for me and I
think just having something you know
what I've already forgotten your three
laughing was one love laugh and inspire
the last one let's not inspire them yeah
yeah so it's like
it's people have have a DD we can't
remember things we haven't a ton of
things happen like the inspired life is
easy is easy to remember like I can I
can share that I've had on people with
crazy long podcast show names that
they're promoting I like I'm on the
interview and I already forgot what the
name of their show is and this is me who
actually cares and it's like I'm a guest
on the show right imagine people who
just quickly tune in and pop out I think
this immense clarity and getting it
getting it shorter 21 motivate you but
also allow other people you want you're
on a mission this is something important
you want people to spread it for you so
it's got to be something that's easy to
spread the longer and harder it is to
remember then the harder it is to spread
unless statement gives your papers as
well because you believe it you think
about it you do it and then all just
falls into place as well so I think it's
valuable to have that ground in no
matter where you're at and even if you
don't actually fully believe it right
now so I'm going to go on to this next
question now which I always love to find
out about people's roots but I think we
actually we've already gone over this
and this was a question was already
poured on you beforehand but tell me
about your family life they know they
were supportive like where you live in
right now and how do they sort of
support you then just tell me a bit
about your family life sure I got about
five minutes we have to hop on to
something else is that so you're a
potentially I just make sure this will
leave out that question will carried out
and August and go into this one then a
couple of questions left a local school
send you a small piece of card in the
post this is one of our it's my one of
my favorite questions okay up it reads
Evan Carmichael's message of self-belief
your words will be displayed in every
school college and university when in
your area what one truth about believing
in yourself would you write and what
inspirational quote would you sign the
card with um what's the question what 11
Ruth about believing in yourself one
truth about believing in yourself
the one truth I think I think I would
tie kind of both into them I'm reminded
of Henry Ford who says whether you
believe you can do it or you can't
you're right love it love it final
question who inspires you a lot of
people inspire me for different reasons
I'm a big believer modeling success it's
the name of my youtube channel modeling
the Masters I'm inspired by my parents
just for the life that they live and
aimed by you know how what I've you at
least great a job they did with me and
instilling belief and confidence in
myself but I'm with intention daily try
to get inspired by great ideas you know
that's the point of the top 10 series in
ian's wrestle series every day I'm
listening to wisdom from successful
entrepreneurs actors musicians inventors
creators politicians you know I've had
Barack Obama on my channel and I've had
Donald Trump on my channel and I've had
Hillary Clinton on my channel and people
are feel like oh why do you have this
this person up on your channel they have
a terrible message and even if you don't
like the person there's something that
you can learn from their success and
somebody was not willing to learn from
Kanye West because he did something
stupid this taylor taylor swift on stage
they're really missing the point there's
a lot you can learn from what he's done
even though you may not agree with what
he believes in and so I find that
surround myself with those ideas every
single day the point of it is not to be
Bill Gates or be Richard Branson or be
Steve Jobs it's to use their knowledge
and wisdom and strategies to help me be
the best version of myself at the end of
the day that's my goal I want to be the
best Evan Carmichael possible not some
copy of somebody else and the way to do
that is to be stretched you know I
watched something from Richard Branson
he stretches me one way and then
chup will stretch me a different way and
and you know I may not like 8 of his 10
rules but those two man has some juice
to it that make me think and stretches
me a little bit further so that could be
a better Evan Carmichael and so that's
the goal and I'm inspired by anybody
who's had anybody who's like following
their passion doing their thing inspires
me to want to push just a little bit
harder that's perfect i love it so much
where can we find you online and support
your dreams you know what just search up
in carmichael you got me on twitter
define on youtube twitter my website
whatever whatever path you like breasts
taken over the internet by now even
thank you so much for every drop of him
for inspiration that you've poured into
my life during the past two years and
really thank you for the passion and
energy that shines through in all of the
videos thank you so much for coming on
my pre share I love it thanks for having
me and honored to be your first guest
good luck with the show you share buddy
cheers Cheers